Michigan a state surrounded by water is
drowning in controversy for years Nestle
the world's largest food and beverage
company has bottled Michigan's water for
next to nothing and sold it at great
profit now the state has greenlit the
company's request to pump even more
despite widespread opposition and all
Nestle has to pay for these millions of
gallons of water it gets a year is $200
and this in a territory where Native
American tribes have treaty rights there
is a perception around the world that
Nestle goes into poor communities with
lacks regulations entices them with the
promise of jobs and then takes their
water sells it back to them at a profit
we have to go with the waters that what
do you think Nestle should do go home to
Switzerland
[Music]
we're walking up to see the white pine
Springs well we're Nestle pumps 250
gallons of water a minute that it
bottles under his ice Mountain brand
despite massive opposition Michigan has
just approved Nestle's request to
increase that amount to 400 gallons of
water a minute and all Nestle has to pay
for these millions of gallons of water
it gets a year is $200 which locals here
are furious about John McLean has worked
as a surveyor in this area for over 30
years he and Peggy case are members of
Michigan's citizens for water
conservation an organization that's been
fighting Nestle for nearly two decades
so we're looking at Nestle's well over
there that's Nestle's white spring well
and it's fenced off because obviously we
cannot even get close to it you can get
within 20 feet since 2005 Nestle has
extracted more than 3.4 billion gallons
of water from Michigan the state doesn't
charge extraction fees for water like it
does for oil and gas and because Nestle
owns this land the company can take as
much water as it wants for a $200 a year
permit fee if there's no harm to the
environment but locals here say the
damage is clear well this is supposed to
be the headwaters of Chippewa Creek
where it starts where this Creek begins
according to Nestle there should be
water here don't see much in order to
grant Nestle's request to pump 400
gallons per minute the state required
the company to run its plan through a
computer model which determined there
would be an adverse impact on the
environment but Michigan's Department of
Environmental Quality or DEQ overruled
those findings and instead relied on
data provided by Nestle to push the
permit through the final hurdle was a
public comment period during which the
DEQ was flooded with more than 80,000
comments against Nestle's request and
only 75 in favor but they approved it
anyway why are you opposed to what
Nestle is doing here well we're opposed
to bottled water and we're opposed to
privatizing water they're taking the
water putting it in plastic bottles
selling it outside of the watershed and
making a huge profit off of water that
doesn't belong to them the water belongs
to the people
locals we spoke to accuse Nestle of
trying to cover up traces of
environmental damage
by offering to replace local
infrastructure like this culvert where
water markings show how levels have
dropped significantly over time the
water used to be up that high feet
higher okay which would have placed it
up above the stones here so you guys
Michigan citizens for water conservation
made noise about how you can tell the
water has gone down by the way they
offered to replace it at the next public
meeting they made that offer do you want
them to do that no why because it would
destroy this evidence
[Music]
the fight for resources in this region
goes back centuries
Desmond berry is a tribal citizen of the
Grand Traverse band of Ottawa and
Chippewa Indians a treaty dating back to
1836 gives the tribe rights to the land
and water in this area the tribe spent
more than a year lobbying the DEQ
against Nestle our treaty rights are
under threat by Nestle a corporation
that proposes to withdraw groundwater at
unprecedented levels which will have an
effect upon surface waters within our
treaty ceded territory where our way of
life is dependent upon access to those
treaty reserved resources such as
fisheries such as wildlife plants
animals have you seen that happen so far
we've seen that happen in this area
where we're standing right now we should
probably be in knee-deep water and we're
not and who's that fault for that Nestle
is at fault for that because about 2000
yards behind us is there well
nestle operates several well fields
across Osceola and Mecosta counties
including the white pine Springs well
opponents say the surface waters of the
two local creeks and river are suffering
as a result the water Nestle extracts
gets pumped to the small town of Evert
and then trucked to the Ice Mountain
factory in Stanwood where it's bottled
and sold all over the Midwest
[Music]
for years critics have accused the
company of exploiting lacks water loss
in economically depressed areas jobs
that's what this tiny town of Evert had
hoped for more than 44 percent of
residents here live below the poverty
line but it's rich in water and for over
a decade Nestle has been purchasing a
lot of that water from two of the town's
municipal wells city manager Zachary
Zakas credits Nestle for saving his town
how much water are they getting from
this well 500 gallons per minute and
what are they paying for that three
dollars and fifty cents per thousand
that sounds like a good deal for Nestle
it's a great deal but you just got to
think of everything that Nestle has to
do to get that water produced they have
to maintain this well this well to
replace it would be almost 1 million
dollars well 1 million dollars one could
argue is a drop in the bucket compared
to their profits could be it could be so
what is in it for the city of effort
then the revenue we generate annually
from them how much is that I just looked
at the numbers for 2017 basically we
generated three hundred thirteen
thousand dollars is that significant
versity its major for a city like ours
despite hopes Nestle never built a
factory never the few jobs that exist
here are at the transfer station where
water pumped from wells gets trucked to
the Ice Mountain plant in Stanwood 40
minutes away instead nestle helped
finance things like new softball fields
a state fairground and a new well did
Nestle effectively buy out your town no
not at all you come up with that I mean
they they have not brought out our town
halls are doing is purchasing spring
water from us it's frustrating that
we're not like puppets
but Everett residence Maryann Borden and
her daughter Rhonda feel differently
okay they built new softball diamonds
across the street from us but we already
had softball diamonds over at the
fairgrounds I mean the things that they
say they've given us and maybe they're a
little nicer but we already had those
things Mary Ann has lived in this home
since 1953 her two children grew up here
playing in this backyard Creek they
claim they've witnessed noticeable
changes since Nestle came to town which
should be a Coldwater stream where trout
thrive is now warmer narrower and more
shallow so what do you think is going on
well somebody is sucking the water out
of my Creek and who do you think that
somebody is I think that somebody is
Nestle and and they'll say well you
can't prove that however they are the
only large corporation that is sucking
water out of my stream by the millions
of gallons that has moved into my
Township Nestle agreed to speak to us at
their ice mountain plant in Stanwood in
2016 the company reportedly sold more
than three hundred and forty three
million dollars of Michigan water under
its ice mountain and Pure Life labels
but that's just a fraction of its
worldwide footprint headquartered in
Switzerland Nestle has over 8,500 brands
in at least 80 countries
Arlene Anderson Vincent is the natural
resource manager for Nestle waters North
America why do you think there was so
much local opposition to Nestle
increasing its pumping there we have a
lots of strong partnerships with
residents and local businesses and
business leaders I don't know if I I'm
not I'm not sure
I'm not sure how much local opposition
that there is well I'll give you an
example we filmed a few people several
people I spoke to who were standing on
the side of the road and fishing trout
and we say how's the fishing going one
man literally said well I don't catch
his money
thanks to ice mountain hmm what do you
say to him then the science just doesn't
show that and I also received a lot of
pictures of people saying look at how
healthy the trout streams are so so
you're not concerned that the area is
being depleted at all by Nestle's
pumping I'm not concerned that there is
being depleted there's genuine concern
among locals who say once Nestle starts
pumping to 400 gallons a minute our
ecosystem here will suffer what do you
say to this book that the science does
not show that we are very confident in
the science we looked at it very
conservatively for our gallons a minute
is a very conservative number as to what
that well could pump and without
negatively impacting any of the
ecosystems we study the ecosystems we
study the stream but Nestle science
relies on subcontractors the company
hires itself doesn't necessarily that
water is a fundamental human right most
ethylene um that's it is a human right
it is most definitely a human right
there is a perception around the world
that Nestle goes into poor communities
with lacks regulations entices them with
a promise of jobs and then takes their
water sells it back to them at a profit
how do you respond to that I don't know
I can't speak to the perception per se
but from the science perspective we have
to go where the water is half so a lot
of times those are gonna be more rural
areas because that's where we've pick up
first it's not heavily industrialized so
that's where from the science
perspective why we're in this area where
why we're at white pine Springs and why
were in Stanwood
[Music]
in 2016
bottled water surpassed soda for the
first time to become the number-one
beverage in the US here in Michigan just
days after the state greenlit Nestle's
request to pump more water the governor
announced Flint residents would no
longer be receiving free bottled water
people we met in Flint called out the
irony tax max leap and give it the flame
that's the slap in the face that's all I
got to say I mean well how would you
feel if you had a two hundred dollar
water bill and a billion dollar company
was getting a billion dollar word for
product for free
[Music]
despite public outcry Nestle's presence
in Michigan appears unstoppable in the
ideal scenario what do you think Nestle
should do go home
just Switzerland I'm serious go home
we don't want bottled water here and we
don't want corporations taking the water
and turning it into a profit
period
[Music]
hey guys it's Deena and we did a lot of
coverage of water problems for this
season on direct from from Cape Town to
Flint to the Nestle story here
check out the direct from playlist to
catch all of those episodes and more be
sure to like and share this video
comment on it and subscribe to aj+
I'll see you soon